even though covet deaths have been on  the decline covid Remains the number  three cause of death in the United  States Based on data through the end of  September you know in 2020 covet was the  number three cause of death and in 2021  covet was the number three cause of  death and in 2022 it Remains the number  three cause of death behind heart  disease in first place and cancer in  second place those who believe that the  risk is over are clearly wrong based on  the data at the same time increasingly  we are seeing covet deaths concentrated  among the elderly and how elderly is  defined differs a little bit depending  on where you look doesn't mean we ignore  it doesn't mean we don't care about it  means that we understand it